[Music]  foreign  [Music]  Catwoman has been in prison for the last  10 years and she's just been let out it  was after an event called Fool's night  which took the lives of the Joker the  Batman and Gordon Selena gets out and  comes back to a Gotham City she barely  recognizes so there are no more costumes  there's no more superheroes or super  villains but there are lots of police on  the streets Selena has to come back and  and see where she fits in as a career  criminal what can she do now and this is  a smaller story about character I used  to work at DC as a as an assistant  editor and it's such a comfortable place  for me and to be given the amount of  Creator Freedom that we have with black  label is just it's unbelievable getting  a chance to do all of it really gives me  a really fine control over the  storytelling  foreign  [Music]